foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're watching on peacock you get to
see Rich Eisen
who joins us right now where are you
right now
uh I'm at the home of FC Bayern uh which
is the you know the Academy of Bayern
Munich the Tampa Bay Buccaneers are
practicing right now
um and we're we're here at the practice
Dan this I'm giving you access uh it's
the media portion of breakfast so oh
there's a bit of German media here and
what the Bucks are doing is they're
showing off punting
okay oh that's what's here can you see
Brady where you are right now oh let's
see hold on a minute all right round
he's in the printable uh uniform all the
way down there watch that ball just
hold on man I do have a quarterback
right here Kurt say hi Kurt not the one
that's playing but what's going on Dan
there you go did Kurt play in Germany
you can ask him yourself Dan well I was
I wasn't here my team was Amsterdam but
I did play in Germany for for one of the
games that I played that year okay all
right uh but not not here in Munich not
hearing music that that part got caught
left on The Cutting Room floor of his
movie last year Dan that was not part of
this movie
how was the uh Hofbrau house last night
you know Dan I had a lot more beer than
I'm used to uh I'm fighting it today
but I'm I'm probable I'm probable though
enlisted is probable for Sunday's
broadcast okay two days from now so
everything's fine yeah uh Peter King was
there and uh devouring some pretzels uh
from what I hear Iran okay at the
Seattle practice yesterday and um he
said let's have a beer I'm like actually
we're gonna be at The Hofbrau house
tonight and
um
uh you've never lived until you've
watched Peter King buy a pretzel at The
Hofbrau house
and I did see that last night Dan that
happened I don't know if I'll make the
the column on Monday but that happened
yesterday can you gauge how big the NFL
is in in Germany yeah no doubt no doubt
just walking around town
um people are all over
um in town and they're not American you
could tell
um somebody with a uh a German accent
came up to mooch asked for an autograph
yesterday
um you know
um here hold on a second come here say
hi to Dan Patrick Michael Irvin tell him
how popular you are here
do they but do they know the playmaker
in Germany
GP the actually we know what it's called
a Spiel marker
Spiel Spiel mocker hey I'm still working
on saying it directly
uh Mike Mike could you signal a first
down for us when you were at the U could
you do you do that for one year here we
go
thank you I'm a little old now
he's not questionable
thank you Mike good to see you I love
you man I love you man good to see you
yeah we're all out we're back uh with
Rich Isaac the skill mocker is very
popular here you can tell there you know
there's there's
um pictures of Brady literally every two
feet you walk in this town
um three million requests for tickets
apparently were had I met somebody who
said they were 25
000th online and an online purchase for
the tickets they never made it they
never got through I mean it's it's quite
something here it's exciting but also I
have to look at this talk talk about the
game itself the opening for the
Buccaneers all you have to do is win
that Division and you're going to host
the playoff game here and right you know
Carolina winning last night in the rain
sort of opens the door for Tampa but
your assessment of Tampa so far this
year and what the expectation level
should be in the second half as well
we're we're going to meet with them
later and um their issue essentially as
far as I'm concerned and I I guess I
should keep it in hush tones since the
running game might be behind me in some
way shape or form but that has been
their issue
um their issue has been running the ball
I mean uh lender foreign at 127 yards in
the opener and he's had 280 yards since
then uh Brady leads the league in
attempts by far he's 38 clear of Kyler
Murray who's half his age so they need
to be more balanced and you know the
Seahawks who we visited yesterday Dan
they they were like
a 10 year old hopped up on a bag of
candy like they were bouncing off the
walls they were just playing music loud
and just having a blast they were going
to you know to a bowling party for Drew
Lock's birthday after the practice last
night I mean they are as they they look
the part of a four-game winning streak
team yesterday and you know it's the
first International Series game where
both teams either have a piece of or
have uh sole possession of first place
against each other so it's gonna be a
great game
but that's the issue with the Bucks is
they're unbalanced right now and I I
don't know how sustainable that is
when we look at European expansion I
don't know where you stand on that but
you know the difference between the feel
you have in London and the feel you have
in Germany is there that much of a
difference
but it's known issues it's real there
really is I mean unless they're they're
all filled with uh Russell Wilson's they
they do suffer from jet lag I mean they
really do you know and it's serious it's
significant and then there's the fan
base as well I mean God bless the
Germans for being into the NFL I mean
the Sunday Night Football game is going
to kick off at three in the morning here
so I I don't I don't know how
sustainable it is
um you know year round yeah uh and I
clearly don't know how sustainable it is
if they don't have their own say
European division here how you know Road
games would be significant to say the
least I don't know how sustainable that
is but the fans here are nuts for it and
the atmosphere is going to be crazy on
Sunday no doubt should Geno Smith be an
MVP candidate and by that I mean top
five top five because we could have 15
MVP candidates but the real the realism
of that is what
the realism of it is just look at his
statistics he is a top five MVP
candidate okay
um he has uh if if I'm not mistaken just
remember for my research seven games of
two or more touchdowns this year uh the
team is uh a legit Super Bowl Contender
right now we're just still stuck on the
fact that Russ is gone and we're still
stuck on the fact that Gino was a guy
who didn't pan out for the Jets and then
even he said yesterday when we spoke to
him is you know he's been ready this
whole time he's been stuck behind three
iron men Eli Philip Rivers and then
Russell Wilson needed to have a broken
finger for him to finally get a shot
um and they believe in him they love him
they love him the whole team feeds off
of him they love his story that that
he's a guy that people overlooked that
entire team feels that that's their
story as well they are absolutely for
real and I think Carol is loving that
nobody saw this coming and that everyone
was writing him off too like it really
is a contagious feeling for that team I
felt it yesterday have you been able to
drive around in Germany
being myself yeah or have you have you
gone places
I have
um I've gone around
um just driven around I took a walk in
the guard in the The Gardens
um you know a little head clearer
um not to bring everybody down but I did
go to Doc out today to see what was
going on you know 80 years ago I did
pass a black commemorating uh the
Americans who liberated the camp on
Veterans Day it was so moving Dan I
can't tell you how moving an experience
that was to be in the uh memorial for
for Dachau and and then tonight
um we're just gonna go hang out and have
a dinner and be around and people here
are so inviting the whole uh country is
really excited for and I feel it I
really do you know how far is the uh
concentration camp outside of Munich
hour okay
I went with Curtin uh Warner and his
wife Kurt and Brenda and boots and Gail
Mariucci the five of us went today
um we couldn't find the uh the
spielmacher in time to to go there so he
um he was doing something else but it
really was moving and like I said to
walk past that plaque on Veterans Day
today
honoring the the U.S uh army soldiers
who liberated the camp
you know I took a picture of it I I I
truly sat down man and I I just thought
about everything going on and how lucky
I am to have walked out of that camp as
a Jewish man and then to be here for a
football game
um uh you know the the export that
America has on the sporting world
it's pretty cool man and Bayern Munich
is involved in it that's we're going to
the home of Bayern Munich the Seahawks
are training on the where Bayern Munich
uh the you know the the big boy club and
this is where you know all the
youngsters who are training to hopefully
join that club one day
um you know come and do their work too
it's pretty awesome Dan great you get a
chance yeah like great stuff great stuff
uh thanks for joining us rich we
appreciate it our best to everybody
there
hey care is this seton's team I don't
know whose team is Bayern Munich does
which one of your guys inspired me well
Paulie's Liverpool yeah Liverpool uh
Seton are you uh Bayern Munich nah more
of a Juventus guy oh Juventus yeah I
don't I and fritzy doesn't know I don't
think yeah
fcfc lafc
there you go all right you're going to
talk to Will Ferrell about that in hour
three I imagine yes yes we will yes now
he's he's a champion
Joe I'm sorry Dan thank you take care
all right that's Rich Eisen NFL Network
host by the way Seattle Tampa rich with
uh Michael Irvin hey uh what what is it
the Spielman spearmacher spielmacher
German for playmaker Steve Mariucci Kurt
Warner Jamie Erdahl and Sarah Walsh and
they will bring you that game 9 30 a.m
Eastern